Over the last few years, this demo has
become a bit of a favourite and it's certainly one that
I can't help but love as well.
All it really involves is some ethanol, which is just ordinary alcohol,
As you can see, it burns with its nice
bluish yellow flame but quite gently. And the reason it burns gently is that it actually has to turn
into a gas before it will burn - it's not the
liquid that's burning
so it can only burn as fast as the
liquid evaporates.
In the case in the bottle, I slosh the ethanol all around
coating the inside surfaces, allowing it to evaporate
and creating this highly combustible
mixture of
ethanol vapour and air which is ready to burn.
If we ignite it and slow down the footage,
you can see that at first, it burns with a really lovely clean blue flame
which is a sign of what is called complete combustion.
This is where these is abundant oxygen to react with the fuel so you just get the classic combustion products
of carbon dioxide and water.
As the reaction progresses, the oxygen starts to get consumed and so,
as well as the carbon dioxide and
water, you start to produce lots of tiny
carbon particles which glow yellow with
the heat of the flame.
There's an interesting thing that you can see
the end of the reaction
which is this yellow billowing flame and  that's probably because of
fresh oxygen being drawn into the bottle
through the normal processes and mixing around
with what's left of the fuel inside
So anyway so far so fun
but besides the fact that this looks really
cool, what I think is interesting about this
is that it's basically just a rocket.
A rocket is a device for burning fuel
and creating a force by projecting the
combustion products
out the back and that's exactly what's
going on here.
So if this is generating some sort to force,
maybe we can get to propel something,
such as me.
That was underwhelming.
So clearly the rocket isn't strong enough to have much of an effect on a mass such as mine.
So let's back up a bit and
see if we can determine how much thrust
it is generating and we can do that crudely
on a balance like this.
So that looked like it produced around 600
grams of thrust.
That's about six Newtons, which is not bad but you can kinda see why
the bottle was a bit out of its depth in trying
to push on me. But the bottle on its own
is around 100 times lighter than I am so let's see how that gets on.
You can really see the acceleration
as the fuel burns.
The burning gas creates a build up of pressure inside the bottle
that simultaneously forces the exhaust out the back and propels the bottle forward.
What we're seeing here is a really
beautiful demonstration of one of the most
fundamental laws in physics - the conservation of momentum.
Where one object, in this case the exhaust gas, moves in the opposite direction to the other object, the bottle,
balancing out the overall momentum and
keeping Isaac Newton,
and therefore the universe, happy.
We can also try some more fuels.
This is methanol, which is similar to ethanol
but has a smaller molecule.
It seems the pack a bit more of a punch.
And this is propanol, which is a larger
molecule with more carbon in it.
You can see that it burns with a lot more the
yellow flame, which you will remember was a sign of unburnt carbon particles.
Now this all looks very rudimentary but
in fact some early rockets
were propelled with ethanol.
The infamous V2 rockets
used by the German army in the second
world war, combined their ethanol with pure oxygen.
Fully fueled, they weighed over twelve tons,
around four which was fuel.
Clearly with the few grams a fuel
we're using here
we're not going to be sending anything into space
anytime soon.
or are we?
Now that's rocket science.
thanks